on this episode we talk video email
Facebook notes and a or employees yeah
that winnie-the-pooh
this is
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 132 on the ask gary vee
show so I really enjoy the random tweets
and Instagram comments facebook comments
of people missing the show that makes me
happy obviously I'm in the midst of some
vacation time this is kind of a working
week vacation spending it with my family
but in the office today I will be back
in the office next Wednesday or eight
night are we taping on Thursday of next
week so we'll get one more in so it's
gonna be a little sporadic here that the
heart is going to grow very fond as we
are in a little bit of a hiatus as I
take family time
I do feel itchy fingers itchy thing I do
feel itchy fingers to possibly have some
of you guys come up and visit me out
east one I think we may have to actually
work on the book a little bit and do
that day and then maybe you can schlep
along and we can bang out a an episode
on location but for the most part I
appreciate the momentum I'm really
excited as we get back into full swing
we will be very focused on football talk
on the show get ready for it and and
those things the other thing that really
excites me India is that I see you have
your shirt which really is cool no I
took it with me and my dad stole hit
mine so now I know I gave it to him but
it sounded cooler to say it stole so
India oh I'm by the way real quick some
of you have been posting photos of you
wearing it which I like which is a lot
of fun keep posting them we will keep
showing the vaynernation
in their show shirts throughout the
episodes over the next 10 or 15 episodes
so India let's get into the show all
right let's do it be Lloyd
be Lloyd be Lloyd be Lloyd asks how do
you handle your employees the ones that
always sound like they're whining and
pessimist
ah haha we fire them because energy is
something I value tremendously and no
question if you are dragging down the
team that is a heavily not having the
smarts to do the work is actually viewed
as a better option than being your and
what was me I'm sure look we are 550
deep now I'm positive
as people watching this from vaynermedia
saying yeah but Ricky is really you are
you say you fire him why is Ricky been
moping for six months I'm sure there's a
couple people sneaking through with what
was me but the truth is I heard a story
this weekend from my mom we had an
employee that was friends with my mom's
friends with his mom and she told me a
story that the doorman and the dork men
say that they know who the vaynermedia
employees are versus not just by the pep
in their step when they go into the
building and they're happy and always
smiling I think we have a pretty good
good atmosphere here and so I'm uh I'm
uh I'm very very very affected by the
atmosphere and the energy of my own
company and since I'm the CEO I I try to
create an environment that allows me to
most do my my thing and I think
companies are disproportionately
affected by the top five to ten people
in a company it's stunning if you even
look at the apples and Nintendo's and
Budweiser Syme it's incredible how a
small group of people really dictate the
outcome and of course everybody's an
impact but for me if I'm not in a good
mood because somebody is moping well
then I that's a problem there's a
negative ROI there so you know truth is
we try to understand what makes them
unhappy now now again moping is
different than being an introvert or
quiet yeah it can be quiet and focused
on your thing that's very different and
I want to make sure and make a big point
here that I actually stunningly
overvalue quiet focused I always worry
that people at vaynermedia don't realize
if they're an introvert or quiet or
focused or headphones on never really
interacting we have such a culture of
intermingling that I it's I would even
argue that I value them not more that's
not fair I just value them for what they
are I don't try to change people for
what they are and
you could bring enormous value to this
company by never saying a word or you
can yell like Gabe 24/7 and bring value
all of it in between really matters for
me and so let's make sure that as you're
watching this if you're auditing your 5
10 15 500 person company that you're not
digging through and misjudging moping
and just quiet or quiet and focused or
introverted like those are tremendously
valuable things that's how they
concentrate and get their job done
moping is debbie downer I think it's
more Debbie where you know like Debbie
down or like this sucks like try to walk
around here for more than 20 days in a
row saying this company sucks try that
is that's not gonna fly you know being
focused maybe not being the most social
flower and going to every you know happy
hour and like high-fiving everybody when
you walk through here that's more than
fine that should be acceptable that is
acceptable at the highest levels but
saying this sucks the client sucks this
work sucks this sucks this sucks just
doesn't work it's too much of a downer
so how do we do what they would try to
cut it out it's cancer straight-up
cancer about the cancer this is cancer I
hope it's not Glenn Glenn Glenn asks
it's the snapchat discover kind of like
billboards there for everyone to see but
people's attention is elsewhere no I
don't think Glenn that is the case I
actually think it's more like the
Facebook newsfeed I think it's there and
it's in the front of your eye and based
on the data of people clicking clearly
the content there is valuable I think
that the thing that you need to
understand about Facebook excuse me
snapchat discover is it is content it is
not at a billboard is an ad and you and
I and Alex let's show Alex cuz the shirt
he's wearing just needs its own
attention today you know so two days in
row we wore that shirt snapchat discover
is content when you click that you know
ESPN or Cosmo or the snapchat logo you
know you're about to get
one-tenth you're not gonna get ads
there'll be some ads mixed in that's a
very different value proposition than a
billboard and we've been all kind of
trained to know that billboard doesn't
bring me any value it's trying to sell
me something versus like TV and print
and radio the reason we tolerate and
still enjoy it is okay I'm gonna get
something of value I'm gonna have to
suffer through being sold to which is
why technology's shifting away from that
is the big rub that I talk a lot about
but discover platform for me is a belief
that it's there as a billboard sure it's
in your face it's there but what is
behind it is the variable and if they
program it correctly they'll email all
the people that program there or the
partners Daily Mail Cosmo is Penn or
snapchat itself if they program
successfully you'll go there a la NBC
ESPN a ABC you know Andy when Walking
Dead is what you program and people want
to go there they'll go there when
schmuck I'm a mug TV show that nobody
wants to watch is there you don't go
there so the content is the variable
knowing that there's content behind that
makes it very different than a billboard
make sense right
Zoltan deserves that that's the most you
know Zoltan asks what do you think about
the revamp Facebook gave its notes
platform a medium contender maybe Zoltan
first I feel like Zoltan I should try to
take on the world let's team up kill the
world truth is I haven't dug deep you
know obviously I've been checked out for
the last 48 hours with the fam and notes
kind of hid out obviously I got pinged
by a lot of people here especially
because I've been pushing the long-form
thing we had a little bit of a
conversation Andy mentioned that it's a
link out thing I haven't really looked
yet so the answer is I can't fully
answer this
help me here real quick India because I
know you had a look at it like it Andy
mentioned that it's linked out right
kind of like like like if you did
YouTube or garyvaynerchuk.com got it so
our point of view and why we talked
about that is when you guys see the box
image and the headline you know you're
leaving a facebook environment that
creates a friction point that the
form post does not but I would say we'll
probably even you know what let's test
the note today and we'll follow up on
133 134 135 I I do think it look I think
Facebook has a very clear plan let's be
the layer on top of the Internet itself
so if anything works YouTube video
medium blog post if anything works let's
have our version of it and let's keep
everybody in our walled garden because
we'll make a lot of money if we do that
and a o L is the only other company that
ever had that kind of ecosystem in the
late 90s mid 90s when people were scared
I was scared to go to the World Wide Web
there was a button up there it was like
the World Wide Web forget it I was in an
AOL world I'm like that's spooky
you know I'm staying in here it's safe
and Facebook doesn't have that advantage
people are more educated they know the
web exists but in a mobile-first world
in a Instagram Facebook whatsapp world
it's why they offer three billion for
snapchat if Facebook on snapchat right
now they would own the entire Alex even
got excited and he keeps a chill I mean
he said I don't know if you heard it
they would own the ecosystem so they're
3/4 of the way there are some other
players but YouTube there's other
players but I I think Facebook's plan is
obvious and I think in general it's very
interesting to watch them navigate I
think it's proper for maximizing
business it's why I'm very bullish on
the company - I haven't sold a single
share of the stock I bought a private
before one public not a share and so I'm
a big believer in it video time check
customs nature hey Gary Vee Travis here
first once a quarter all you do with the
askgaryvee show must definitely be
buying the book when it releases
question for you is you talk a lot about
the use of twitter native video and i
can personally say i've seen a lot of
really great results with engagement it
almost got me reamped about using the
Twitter platform again you've received
this type of video response
functionality and being built natively
and some of the more common email
clients anytime in the near future let's
be practical for someone like you who
travels a lot and who has a lot of mass
email volume to go through would love to
hear your thoughts thanks for your time
Travis we're gonna keep it tight you're
like one Bone Thugs on that real fast um
I watched Scranton last night oh my god
I loved it I loved it
so so what I think is really interesting
on that is I made I wish Erik Kastner
was here right now let's show castner's
a Twitter profile at Kastner KS TN er
Eric was the developer that sat right
next to me that helped me build up
winelibrary.com and I made a prediction
to him in 2004 or 5 or 6 or 7 that all
email would be video in five to seven
years I'm glad we weren't doing the
askgaryvee show back then because boy
that highlight the lowlights of the show
but I can't wait for the lowlights and a
couple years of all my wrong things and
this cuz those are fun too that's not
really so I think the answer's no I
think that what people don't realize is
most people don't want to be on camera
and this is a really interesting thing
now what's happening right now with
everybody growing up in selfie culture
and all these 15 14 13 year-olds just
owning this move I do think that
behavior is changing and I do think that
videos upside over a 15 to 30 year
period 15 to 30 years from now 15
through 30 years from now is very high
because I think we're training
youngsters 7 8 9 10 11 12 to be more out
to be more and from the camera it's not
this kind of thing anymore so I I'm
bullish on the concept of it I do think
email is ripe for a change in the next
generation I think you know Gmail's
gotten heavy
it started off lighter I think there's
some real opportunity I do think when
you look at slack and how people use
that in companies to communicate I think
a version of texting Twitter video and
email the Frankenstein of that eight
nine years from now has a real shot and
then there's gonna be a technology we
don't understand like Holograms like
Princess Leia pops up and Star Wars
I'd like that even better I'd like yeah
I could use my hands you know be great
so I think that um I think a lot of
technology will come and I do think
they'll be changed I do think that video
in email clients like Gmail and Apple
Mail is going to be smaller than you
think because people don't like to go
that route it actually takes longer and
I think time is the biggest
I said I think people can type it out
quicker then click that so and I think
we're writing less you know a lot more
emojis a lot I mean you know these guys
will probably laugh right now I mean my
emails are tight they're very much in
the k-lol cool go yes no I mean I'm
keeping it tight and so I mean when I
write two or three sentences people are
like oh so so I think that a time is the
biggest variable
besides people's non want to be in
picture form you think about how many
people don't want to take pictures of
themselves they don't wanna see
themselves that's a very big culture
underrated especially for the generation
that's in the workforce now the younger
generation I didn't change that over
time Oh Roo Roo Roo Roo I mean I know
him really well I just maybe I interact
with him a lot I just don't know if he
could perhaps is a true real asks you
don't talk much about tumblr do you
think it's losing relevance yes you keep
asking what you know yes I do think it's
losing relevance I think tumblr lost its
moment which is tough for me because I
was an early investment tumblr I made a
lot of money when it's sold to Yahoo but
it's part of a bigger company that's
selling media in a traditional way even
though it's Yahoo and I think that it
lost to Instagram in the mobile
translation much like many people did it
is still a very high rated app in the
App Store if you look in the top 100s
usually around number 90 to 110 but I I
do think it's losing relevance I think
there's a lot of people that love it
it's still a very big platform but I
don't see huge growth in it I don't see
it
I think it's a it's a niche now where a
lot of creative people are doing their
thing it's a great creative outlet a lot
of people are doing their anonymous work
on it but then snapchat came along and
kind of created a world where India
what's going on behind me what no no you
were laughing before okay I'll have to
watch that partnership
i I think the show I do think tumblers
lost its momentum and would need to have
some real innovation to take get going
again so yes I don't talk about it a lot
because it's not on top of mine and it's
a current show right like like this is
gonna always follow the path of what I
think is most going on I just want to
thank everybody for watching the show I
realized over this weekend a little bit
over the break of just how much this
community means to me really enjoy the
amount of people that have jumped out of
lurker Ville and started commenting it
really means a lot to me it is
absolutely my oxygen in lieu of like the
financial aspects you know as many books
as I sell a bass carry be the time
commitment doesn't work math wise and so
I asked myself what what is it really
and I think it's our interaction and I
definitely think it's our interaction
and so thank you so much for a lot of
people that jumped out over the weekend
and said of a lurker here's my comment
on the latest show question of the day
what do I want to know about Labor Day
is coming up so funny these question
days are coming harder because I really
don't know what I want to know they
become less self-serving from a data
perspective so question of the day what
is your fate I guess the I'm going
self-serving what is your favorite
football team and one after one
preseason game is the prediction for
your team's record this year side note I
may change question of the day as in
fact I'm changing it right here on the
spot we're gonna improv no more question
today this is it this will be part of
the acquit this is 132 this will be part
of the quiz game one day what episode
did it go from question of the day to
comment of the day please make your
comment on the content that you just
watched you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them